if it's great to see but darling
stay with me Janelle Evans in tears as
she regains custody of her son Jace who
Teen Mom fans remember from way back
when here we go
fast forward to 2023 the reality star
announces the Milestone on Tick Tock
showing herself signing documents and
the caption it's official Janelle takes
the celebration to her car holding up
the papers and writing it's done to the
soundtrack of Sam Smith Stay With Me
[Music]
Stay With Me
Janelle's getting custody of Jace who's
now 13 from her mother Barbara Evans
who's been her grandson's Guardian since
2017. as Janelle tells it in her Tick
Tock her mom is completely fine with the
change and with all that new free time
she's already planned a cruise Janelle
answer post with a message words can't
describe how happy I truly am our family
is complete now thank you Mom I know
you've been doing better I know that you
know I'm very proud of you for what
you've been doing the emotional moment
comes after some highs and lows for
Janelle who wasn't invited to last
year's Teen Mom reunion that was packed
with ogs it's time for us to start
getting real with each other
I'm in this for Life the show's been
great to me my family and I'm forever
grateful I love the purpose that all of
us moms have
for doing the show and what our goal is
fans remember that Janelle along with
husband David Eason were fired by MTV in
2019 following a string of controversies
including David shooting their family
dog as for the couple they've had their
ups and downs as well but following
years of an on-again off-again
relationship Janelle's rep says they're
currently together and strong
Mommy here for you
Janelle recently shared their date night
out writing in the caption I guess he
loves me see his front teeth are
sticking out and there's another
milestone in Janelle's next chapter
let's get my boys some braces she
documented Jace and her son Kaiser whom
she shares with ex Nathan Griffith
getting braces together about two weeks
later when they finally were ready to
get their braces on
small quickly went away hopefully this
fixes Jace's overbite but not before
they spooned up a healthy send-off treat
we went and got some pliable if you
don't know what pliable is go look it up
look at that it's like a big fruit bowl
it's so good I was like boys show me
your bowls
force your kids to try new things
because they'll like it yeah it seems
like Janelle's turned a new corner
[Music]